i worry about you
out there in the middle of nowhere all
by yourself the cartels are running
everything through there
drugs people guns i don't scare easy
i've seen darkness who's the best dog in
the world and i've seen
what we can do come from pima county
merchants bank let you know that the
ranches be sold at auction
i just need a little time to sort things
out
you're never gonna make it it's miles to
the nearest road i'll call border patrol
i come here to take the woman and the
boy i was in the marine corps so i
suggest you all turn around and adios
i'm a soldier too my orders are to take
them back with me
you're not safe here let's go
what the hell were you thinking taking
that kid they were going to kill him
they were waiting for him at the border
dare me a lot of appreciate what i'm
doing for you you want to help me you
take me back i'll find my own way home
i'm taking you to your family in chicago
after that i don't care what you do
the man you saw at the border is from
the vasquez cartel
he'll find you and when he does he will
kill you
[Music]
this kid didn't bring him if this on
himself
he just needs someone to give him a
chance
do you think i like in chicago there are
good times ahead for you miguel
he's your grandson no his mother asked
me to look after him she must have had a
lot of faith in you
we've gone home
looks like you had a little incident
[Music]
[Music]
you